and the key battleground state of
pennsylvania a ballot counting was
stopped
briefly in the biggest city of
philadelphia democrats appealed against
a ruling that allowed observers to watch
the process
the trump campaign earlier said a team
had been given access to the process
accounting there has now resumed listen
guys
democracy dies in darkness this is the
opportunity to shed light on what's
going on inside this building
our observers are going to be six feet
behind every person who's counting these
votes in accordance with the covenant
protocols
this is a win for every person who's
cast a legal ballot
in the state of pennsylvania we're going
to go in here right now we're going to
start
watching what's going on not from 30
feet away
not from 100 feet away from six feet
away this is a win and what you will see
is that democrats are going to try and
stop this from happening
they're going to repeal this decision
because they don't want the american
people to know what's going on in here
all right well let's go to philadelphia
dw stephen siemens is in front of the
convention
center welcome stefan so what's the
situation now
well let me tell you something as you
can see here right behind me there's
trump supporters i'm seven hour pictures
facing off pro count the vote
activists very very peaceful kind of a
festival
environment and vibe here but what's
going on behind me
is that until just recently a few
minutes ago
nothing was going on inside there was no
counting because it had
temporarily halted why democrats had
asked a higher court
to nix the decision to get away with a
decision or make away with a decision
from a lower court
which had allowed trump the trump
campaign to send in more
observers and the exclamation point here
is behind observers those people are
just watching what's going on they're
not assessing they can't interfere
they're just looking at how the counting
process works out now however
it seems to be the case that this has
resumed and that the counting here
in philadelphia has resumed right now so
why would democrats be
against observers watching the process
[Music]
sorry i didn't understand that say that
one more time please yeah why are
democrats against uh
observers watching the process
oh yeah well they say there are already
observers in the ballot count process
involved and that is true
they are observers democrats trump trump
campaign
supporters who are observers who are
looking at how this all works out
and of course the government here the
city government and the state government
says over and over again like there is
really no reason to be anywhere
or cast any suspicion on what the
process is here what's happening is here
that
count what's counted are mail-in ballots
and those are the ballots which people
sent in via the united postal service
or dropped off in a ballot drop-off box
which have a post stamp
november 3rd that was the election day
and those are counted
now now the trump administration
obviously
does as they have said so does not want
those ballots to be counted
now two days after the election
okay we see lots of crowds behind you
there uh stefan
it sounds very loud what's the mood
actually like
it is very loud again let me step
outside here a little bit you see there
trump supporters flags posters
they are separated by a line of police
in uniform on civil closing
and if my cameraman pants to the other
side there you see
the pro count didn't
count all the votes protesters or
activists and they're giving each other
so to speak
a a yell or a even dance
off here we have seen dancing and
hauling and everything
it's peaceful it is absolutely peaceful
everybody every side makes
uh the other side listen to what they
have to say or not
all right uh good to hear that stefan
siemens in philadelphia thank you so
much